on this week's show how to set up a
buy-to-let property business is it
possible to buy a house with no money
and under a week in the news MPs say the
home leasehold system needs reform and
will be answering all your property
related questions in the question and
answer session
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS
I am Alister Cunningham now welcome to
the property investors podcast in our
new home here on Samuel Letts Channel oh
we're on Saturdays now so that's pretty
cool yeah yeah it's pretty awesome so
tell us I know you can't tell us much
but tell us about your week okay so um
literally just got back from America
yeah with Samuel it was interesting I
saw we'll see it was interesting it was
fun it was tyrant it was hard work what
I will say for people that don't get
this Samuel is a frickin driven
workaholic crazy madman he just doesn't
stop and I mean I'm I don't stop either
but where he stops even less than you
yeah he's like he's just crazy he's just
on it all the time which is brilliant
yeah surely you knew that anyway that
well I didn't know that sore but it's
just to make a living for a week yeah
it's basically live with them for a week
in the same hotel room cuz we shared
hotel rooms and everything could you
live with him no could you be his
flatmate no why
just because because why I'm not gonna
go into that on this because I ain't
gonna lie he's a messy bugger any
message yes
look he'll oh yes could never live with
Samuel no do you know what it was
phenomenal the week was brilliant it was
absolutely brilliant but it was hardcore
like constantly 6:30 7 o'clock in the
morning
until early hours every day every single
day yeah
pure Sergey was like we could have a
gonna have lunch we're gonna have a
break yeah yeah Leah - I've just been
working a lot it's just you know we've
we've got a lot of new members of staff
recent yeah
every time I come back to the office for
the day there seems to be more people in
there yeah and more desks and the disks
were getting smaller - family men who
Alex gone from a big day still small
this he's got two desks now yes cuz
they're both small this sort of desks at
my my fourteen my earth my 14 yard my 12
year old daughters got in a bedroom for
a busy yeah it's been yeah I must the
met the the office vibe has been really
good recently as amazing yeah amazing
it's awesome right so on this week's
show we're gonna be first of all we're
gonna be looking at how to set up a
buy-to-let property business and someone
that's wanting to get started in
property what steps they need to we
meant just a few times but it's
important that you treat property
investing as a business hundreds it's
not a hobby it's a business and if
you've got the business mindset and you
and you see it as as a business it you
can know what I've said this many times
if you treat anything like a hobby
you'll get hobby results whereas if you
treat it like a business you get
business results I think if you're gonna
do it you've gotta take it seriously and
you've got to set up correctly from the
beginning there's no point doing it
half-hearted because you will only get
half-hearted results yeah yeah so let's
go through the steps something that
you've done recently yeah so what would
you say is setting up I slept business
what would you say was the first thing I
suppose the first thing you need to know
is that is how are you gonna are you
gonna buy properties in your own name
you're gonna buy them through a limited
company so the first thing I would do
before do anything is I would go and
seek advice from your accountant I
wouldn't do anything without speaking to
an accountant first what about if you
don't have an accountant they find one
they're everywhere
Google accountants particularly property
accountants if you if you can find an
account in this very good in property we
are always like maybe
work yep so go to some property dear
honey molesters Network and you got like
pin which is very good we your picket
yeah one cousin Arabic yeah there's the
next ones and me because of the eviction
okay but yeah so I would say that's
because I'm getting evicted from my from
his house yes we've got networks very
good way because I mean at the peak we
have our an account in there every month
he's actually they allocate he's not
he's not there for me but he just comes
to to watch and be able to speak he's an
accountant but well the good thing is
then if you've got an accountant that
understands property yeah
and get rather than just a Bob basic
boring accountant oh wait I always find
difficult working out whether or not an
accountants good because I obviously
don't know very much about accounts yeah
compared to any account yeah so how do
you gauge whether they're good or not
they're gonna be better than me
I'll tell you about there I'll tell you
what um I've always had fairly good
accountants now an accountant what is
worth their weight in gold if you can
get a good accountant doesn't know how
much he's gonna charge you because
whatever he charged you he will save you
as much in tax so a lot of people will I
see this a lot people on the like
property investors which I'm Elise
Facebook group everyone's like oh then
I'm not a cheap accountant hmm I
wouldn't want a cheap accountant that if
my accountant said I'm gonna charge you
in two hundred pound a month or two
three grand a year whatever I don't know
I would happily pay it if you you don't
want a cheap accountant because then
you're gonna get rubbish results and
cheap results yeah and you're gonna have
higher tax bills but you must have a
property really at the counted I would
see because for instance if you'd run
the car I rent to rent business and the
buy-to-let business they are categorized
differently because one's an asset ones
not an asset and things that are and the
tax differently in the set up
differently so so far legal account good
encounter get some advice do I set up a
limited company do I know if you decide
that limited company is the way to go
yeah would you get your accountant set
it up or do you say how I set my
business up yeah right this is but this
is how I done it this is just from my
experience and so I went limited because
countin advise me to and I just set the
company up on a company called a company
our website called companies made simple
the cost like complicated this really
yeah was and they say 35 bought in pound
I've just come back from America it's
once inbox it's like five bucks pound
and they'll set the company up for you
it's very very simple open a bank
account
get yourself insurance as I don't know
the exact date maybe Nick can find out
this and put it in the comments or put
it below but all landlords need to be a
member of the PRS system soon that being
a part that property right reader skin
did you are all landlord sir it's coming
in soon I don't know the exact date but
it is coming very very soon and so you
may not have to do it today but
certainly in the next six months we have
to be a member of the PRS scheme as a
reputable landlord and also make sure
you've got suitable insurance because
obviously one of your tenants if
something goes wrong you got understand
that you're responsible for your tenants
yeah so again it cuz what's in a
business it's a business a business you
need to be in the right I would also
highly recommend being somehow the r-la
yeah absolutely yeah all the yeah NLA I
was only saying what star really the
residents residential laminate
Association Anneliese national landlord
Association yeah they're kind of the
same yeah you're in the NLA on yeah yeah
yeah I'm in the r-la oh yeah yeah little
I don't know why I picked that one but
they're really good I would definitely
do that but do you know why I think
people don't set their business up
properly in the first place because
they're not making much money from
property like some people would go out
and buy a bottle a and they might see
it's the the mortgages to three hundred
plan a month and that the rain is six
hundred only making 300 plan a month so
they do everything a little bit
incorrectly yeah and so that cuz they're
not making much profit from it they then
scrimp skimp and save all on things like
insurances and things out and then
before you know what they've become a
rogue landlord and they're letting the
whole site down so just probably from
the beginning it's gonna cost you better
money by the end of the to say any
business up cost money if you if you're
trying to do it with with them to cut
corners then you take us through the
steps so
first of all if we go through steps okay
we're gonna get a good accountant good
accountant find out what yeah say a
limited company company yeah
come restructure what you mean I'm a
limited sole trader however you doing it
insurances in LA are LA so what what
insurances would you recommend them
getting ill and those issuers oh your
insurance industry business you probably
need public liability and because
obviously you've got you've got people
staying in your property and also like
property redress Kim you're happy
property redressed I don't like to say
that it can put the date down but I
don't that's not effective yet but it's
coming very soon and it's just to get
rid of all these issue your landlord
your em tenants got somewhere to
complain if something goes wrong yeah
yeah
it's also worth having an accountant to
make sure that you put your D tax
returns you've got it you know you've
got a putting everything through the
books a respect of what if it's a it's a
business in the doesn't matter it
doesn't just so happens that our product
is our house and our less but like for
instance you could set up a car it's no
different sitting up like a car sales
business you still set the business up
crazy is a business you need to be
thinking through things like your cash
flow your goals yeah what is it you
wanting to achieve and we talked about a
lots of different strategies I rent to
rent
yeah and deal sauce in all sorts of
stuff so okay what what is it
why are you getting property in the
first place what's your goals what what
are you wanting to achieve how much
money you wanted to make you need to
know all this stuff so that you can then
try and achieve it yeah on set you set
your goals work out what actions you
need to take in order to hit those goals
educate yourself get on things like the
crash course training you're crazy yeah
some it amazes me happy only people by
going to property with very little
training yeah you'd never go into normal
profession you wouldn't would you
oh I want to become a doctor yeah yeah I
watched a video on YouTube once and so
I'm pretty sure I can be the surgeon no
it's I used to see this in my old
industry and engineering background and
people would just come in after watching
a couple of videos and they leave they
fix their mates in car or buy a barn or
whatever and then suddenly they're an
engineer now it's rubbish you need to
get trained
you need to know what you're doing and
you need to budget accordingly so things
go wrong in houses hmm all the time I I
don't think I've had a month and one of
my properties now for I can't remember
the last time I think I've been equal
running on houses and so like the one
who over Hampton for the last three
months there's been some sort of
maintenance issue and you've got to
budget for that you've got to have the
the funds available for that mm-hm so
when you get your rent
don't spend it put it in a business
account just leave it and build it up
and then when you get to a certain
amount Lee you take some money out but
don't just spend it every time it comes
in because like for instance my gas bill
at my current property the the H and
walk around a corner the gas but was
really Express the expensive take 300
pound a month which is just stupid
Oh something's at door one yes we let
them in no and because of that we've
there is it's because I had an
old-fashioned like heating control
system so the tenants kept putting
everything on constant so the gas was on
constantly like there the heating was on
constantly so we last month it cost like
300 quid to get the car digitally
controlled so our heating system put in
you know one of those the controls the
heating from your own no I don't I don't
have nothing to do with it my management
company does but they control the
heating for the tenant they set it and
they leave it oh really
yes man 100% I'm not paying listen my
tenants get a bed that they've got a
warm house they've got lots of hot water
but I'm not gonna what is the point in
the water the hot water being on when
they're not they are just so winch how
do you know if they're there or not I
don't care they're not having all day
100% they've got live in your house and
you control when they're allowed hot
water that is very standard you speak to
any management company they'll say the
same if you hate to more management
coming up spoke to the wall said why
have you not got a nice the wyvern I've
got a nice are a hive in there and I'm
like well yeah if I can do it would you
recommend so they've done it and they
don't they don't control at they just
set it so that they can't go above a
certain temperature okay
23 degrees I think so what was happening
was you know
we've had landlords obviously with quick
move yeah
who will insist on freak they would do
things like lock the thermostat yeah
yeah they'd set the thermostat to 19 and
then they'd lock the cupboard they
couldn't change it it's just like but
like they are living there that cold
like I would hate that you know I was
living I know I pay my own bills it's
different but I want to be able if I
want to put turn the temperature up you
can temperature down yeah hunt it down
so that let me just clarify my property
is immaculate the heating that whenever
you when there's warm but what was
happening was I was going to the
property my manager was going to the
property and the heating was cranked up
to like 27 28 degrees with the windows
open all the bedroom and windows were
open so that they're just heating that
is putting it on for the sake of it and
they don't need to put it on and it's
got a electric shell there's a balance
because at the same time I sometimes
like to have the window open because a
bit of fresh air to come in
yeah I can't but when I'm paying three
underpin a month just for gas it's not
happening
it's not happening that didn't include
electric that's just for gas that's a
law for h'mong yeah so anyway we've
sorted out sort of know the heat in
school but stairs they're on his phone
I'm 19 18 degrees they they won't die if
it's 14 say me 10 quid who cares right
freeze to not deaf that would be bad but
freeze not at all my just come an extra
blanket no seriously I'm not a bad
London I'm a frickin awesome landlord
I am a absolutely I don't know I think
that a tenant should have the right to
be able to have the temperature at the
temperature that they want it to be okay
to save a couple of quid that's not a
couple of quid Russ it's not I know so
many hate you more landlords right that
there I've got the temp John hives so
they can control it I know but it's
because what will happen is when this is
what happens when you the only argument
you've got with it being a Hachem oh
yeah the only and and and is that like
this for people or whatever live in
there
so someone's got to decide what
temperature is because they can't all
have it in the temperatures they want
yeah yeah so you pick a fair temperature
so that everyone's happy well they all
have them teams of controls in the
bedroom and the radios right so the
other animals there like there someone
bought a washing machine all right I
hate show there wasn't a washing machine
there they bought what was it a drives
dryer right they bought a dryer and they
were like no they don't have to have a
dry their electricity it's like really I
googled it and it like a dry it's like
if they used it every day like 20 quid a
month yeah you know it's not it's like
get a grip the tightness the tightness
of some landlords now I know you're
Scottish
so you're making me out to be a tight
land or not I'm not making you're making
no not at all not at all
right yeah okay and my actual my hate
you more manager and this is true I use
a company called rooms too late okay and
in Wolverhampton they've told me many
times I'm the best landlord they've got
because I don't ever question any
maintenance the best best landlord
they've got us what they told me how
many loans they got to know they've got
I don't know I don't know but they've
got a lot look after a lot of rooms and
they've told me that I'm the best
Randall they've got because whenever
they bring me is here as a maintenance
issue or they need destiny that I just
say sort of yeah I'm not necessary
saying it's not necessarily saying that
your tire although I am so I don't know
where I'm going with this near do i I
was no I'm not as serious I'm not
necessarily saying that you talk I'm
just saying that the amount of tight
landlords are just I'm just like guys
get a grip but maybe and you're maybe in
your case maybe that they had the
temperature at 30 and we put in the time
that's what it is but I know so many
landlords that do this and yeah anyway I
just think that some some landlords I'm
not saying that you're like this but
some of the landlords are way overly
controlling of the temperature it's just
anything the stuff that they use it's
like guys I mean you want to give you
and if it was if I wasn't anything you
like it's there I feel like it's my home
I don't I feel like even if it was a
hotel that I want the option to turn my
heat you know bore an attorney but
anything on a shower every sink ball
it's got an electric shower that gets
hot instantly so the the showers not
doesn't matter but hot water
so bad and but but I run a hot well I
won't hold on all the time I never want
to go and wash my hands in the old water
there is holes there's do you understand
how the heating systems work yeah
no you don't you clearly don't because
basically what you're saying is you want
to turn it off so if this one has a bath
for example what will run out this hot
water tanks so so will it will run out
yes or no it will all eventually run out
if they run the water if the lake drain
the system's out and they never want
that to happen
I went to in fact you know the Oxford
property yeah right piss me off when I
was there why is it you that's turned
the heating on Phil over there was it
you this switch the American here on yes
because the bath water that much hot
water I was like oh right
and I didn't realize so I left the hot
tap on and it was freezing so I didn't
want a bath window over in the window
house I don't disagree with you good
the the the the bath Oxford do you not
think was very small yeah it's about
that size and it's tiny
I just feel it nicely did you struggle
no I'm fine by me Oh taller yes taller
do you know I've not missed this yep all
right and a wave to eat scissor has been
fun alright let's move on okay so but
but it's a business your control yeah so
control your spending also couldn't
budget so don't spend your money because
believe me when you've spent all that
money the boiler will break or yeah the
door will break or something I guess
like any business when you start when
you start a business you have a business
bank account you want to build money up
in the account before you start taking a
wage or anything out of it now the
alternative to running it as a business
yeah is we talk we talked a few weeks
ago about the difference in a property
or property entrepreneur yeah and a
property investor the difference would
be if you wanted to just add Hokkien vet
you could treat it like a hobby
yeah you could be like okay well I've
got 40 grand available I'm gonna buy a
house
I'm not gonna treat like a business but
I'll just gonna I'm just gonna own a few
houses and that's fine as well but it's
fine it depends on what they want that
not really well it's not all in a few
problems but you've still got to treat
like a business because things will
still go wrong in that property depends
on their personal situation they might
be someone's got 50 gramme they don't
want you like a business they've got
loads of money in the bank that's fine
but yeah they just want to buy a few
investment properties and keep it simple
and agent look after it yeah but
ultimately doesn't matter if they've got
a lot of money well I suppose if they've
got millions in the bank it's not like
them changing the borders not gonna be
an issue well if you've got thousands in
the back changing a ball it's not gonna
be that much of an issue no but you have
that millions how many people do we meet
on a day-to-day basis that are strong
that are doing this with very little
money yeah because most of our listeners
are gonna be doing this but not as much
we made a trying into property with very
little money exactly right so yeah they
need to Elizabeth they need to run it
probably is if there's someone listened
this has got a hundred grand in the bank
that's just thinking do you know what I
don't care yeah yeah I'm work full-time
I haven't got time for his business you
can do it as a hobby yeah it's not as
effective yeah if you've got the money
if you've got money so it is another
option because it is alright cool
awesome
so hopefully you guys have found that
pretty helpful with basic steps that you
that you need and the Matt and the main
point that I took from all that is that
Alastair it's a tight landlord so I hope
you've got that as well yes such a
douchebag I'm not tight landlord okay
but do you know how much rent we post I
don't know
thanks for nothing it's dark it's late
we're in the hood so big question is it
possible to buy a house with no money in
a week now the reason we're asking this
question is because I'm sure many of you
will have seen the first two parts of
Samuel as documentary basically the
challenges he had to go to a random city
turn up at an airport go to a random
city foreign country and buy a house
with no money and he'd give himself a
week to do it he ended up going to
America I have no york/new which I think
must be one of the worst places to go to
try and buy a house with no money yeah
it's what's New York I say going to
London it's crazy
the problem is everywhere in America
everywhere in New York is coping a hop
yeah like there's houses that were
there's properties that were like last
year two or three hundred thousand there
no six hundred thousand it's crazy yeah
honestly and we make quite a few
investors and we met an investor in
fallen short but we have to come by some
get some American forms could i SIM
cards and we don't have any we couldn't
use our UK SIM cards either
and then it just turns out that the guy
behind we got chatting to him and he's
an investor and he buys he actually does
our strategy called buying a Bynum flip
he flips on he doesn't know he doesn't
rent out he doesn't want tenant and he's
making a killing
he really his Goods the house prices are
rising it's rising so fast and he buys
in Staten Island and New Jersey yeah
interesting when someone told me about
the challenge he was like oh I thought
he the idea was he had to do a deal so
whether it be flipper deal like you said
or or a deal sauce or or some things I
know actually but the challenges I'd
want to buy a house with no money he did
bite offer I think he did pay offer I
was a massive challenge yeah it's a big
challenge I'm a masochist it'll be a
massive challenge here yeah but to do it
in a city and if you if you haven't
watched the the documentary so far I
mean I don't know the end result no and
people don't believe me when I say that
like it
they seriously won't tell me I thought
they would I was like yo how's it going
bro is like you have to watch the
documentary yeah what no yeah I think I
know where anyone knowing
I don't anyone don't want it going out
sworn to secrecy
no not telling anybody so but it's it's
very very interesting seeing him having
to work so hard to put into practice all
the strategies that obviously work but
can they work in New York or in America
and can they work within a week today
did you see the first document do the
very first one we're done it's when we
were in the cab we went to a networking
event yeah yeah hilarious
well you were on the phone to me oh yeah
we were we did for you to vote and they
didn't tell me I only realized that that
conversation had been filmed and put on
YouTube when I saw it on YouTube so you
say by the way just so you're aware I'm
filming this conversation it was just
put on YouTube it was funny telling me
guys thanks that we we found the
networking event and we it took us a
good hour and a half two hours to get
there yeah and we got there we sat in a
room and it was about eight people in
there to begin with so we thought okay
it's small networking event that's fine
and then this was like including YouTube
yeah yeah so there was yeah eight
including ours and then two speakers so
there was those four people no no there
was eight than me and there was 10
people talking and then the guy
introduced himself started speaking and
he asked for like we were we were like
random to them so we asked why we were
there and who we were so we told that
and then he literally said look everyone
is here for the the private sort of a
training session if you can just leave I
go into the room next door and we'll
crack on with that and look how common
the networking event so we like just sat
there and then all of a sudden we just
mean Samuel way it was just the two of
you and then the guy the guy hosting it
he spoke for like 45 minutes
disappeared Samuel I can't imagine a
worse crowd networking event and it was
just I mean obviously it'd be different
for me because
I know you guys really well if I turned
up for speed get turned up but it was
you and Samuel and that was his crowd it
was he was he like awesome or was he
nervous no I think he started off being
a bit like like he's the man do you know
I mean I think they're he's the man I
think it amongst their the network and
it's people that are there I think he's
the one who you guys were
you didn't know no I didn't know that
we're killing like we're doing really
well in the UK but him at that network
company he's probably like the the door
and he's probably the one that's doing
all the deal wasn't what sort of stuff
and because nobody else had actually had
done many deals like there or they'd not
actually going properly around for that
and then about five minutes into the
networking event he sort of just
happened to say oh look what you guys do
like so we we told him very and a cut
down version what we didn't think Simon
didn't go oh yeah I've got this castle
and all that but he said well how many
for how many flips have you done so then
like Simon looked at me and 300 because
obviously I've done like 16 same was
done a lot and then he went oh oh it was
very awkward and it was funny it was
hilarious did he go do you guys want to
do the presentation he didn't at that
point you would think you would realize
that what he's teaching us he would just
sort of stop yes stop and just have a
chat but no he didn't he went through
his slides and it was all like do you
know what financial freedom is yeah do
you know that if you put money in the
bank it shrinks yeah you know if you
heard of Robert Kiyosaki have you seen
this EB is I mean like yeah we had lunch
we had dinner with him last year and it
was just a little bit awkward but in
fairness he done well because he
probably probably felt a little bit I
don't know say intimidated but he
probably felt a little bit like yeah
it's not me at least you guys weren't
like when we weren't laughing out and we
weren't taking the mickey out of them
like we were being polite and basically
it turned out to be our I know we're
along sort of sales pitch for their own
online video training course
yeah great thanks thanks a lot
not nice way to I said it was it was
quite interesting but so that's the
challenge anyway and that's but I would
definitely would watch it watch it it's
I mean the strategies do work wherever
they can work in New York or in America
in a week is another thing very
interesting to see I think it's gonna be
really difficult but I don't know
I think Samuel realized very quickly
that this is this is hard yeah I saw I
saw his post on Facebook you know I
never felt this much rejection in ten
years and and guys we were hustling yeah
we were hustling 13 14 hours a day and
we weren't we weren't Dawson you were
hustling in the hood hustling and who'd
wearing that shirt no not we wearing a
hoodie no I will say I've never seen so
I've seen more crackheads in the last
week than I have in the last year and
you live in Northampton yeah don't get
much ice and there Northampton
unfortunately I don't know what's
Breaking Bad crystal meth you don't get
much crystal meth as ice yeah yeah yeah
that's the Chevy straight no I'm not
very stressed the gangster name is the
gangster name and that was me it was
brilliant it was a hustle it was busy
think my favorite was where you're there
in your life it's cold it's dark we're
in the hole do you know what that was we
were we'd been at it a long time a long
long time it was getting late it was
getting dark we were em what just like I
did notice though about that whole
section someone bazoom pointed out I was
like that's true actually you were the
one that suggested going I'm knocking on
doors right and then you're where you're
doing it you're there like going oh [ __ ]
stupid this yeah that's fine but we've
been doing that old pee like I know that
the video that we used released is what
they only shows four or five door knocks
we must have knocked and 3040 hoses
honest I promise you and the problem is
we just come from our a place where
literally we were the only white people
and literally you've got people looking
at the cartons and things that are and
like suddenly hanging around an
undercover British police that's
probably what they thought they probably
thought that samuel was I don't know
detective or something cuz he was
dressed in a suit and but in answer to
the question is it possible to buy a
house with no money it is it is whoever
whether he manages it or not of course I
think it's possible yeah but you've done
it yeah well yes you using the lease
option agreement what I did layin out
there long do you know what's the
average time it takes to complete in a
house here nah months yeah up there you
can do it in weeks
yeah you can so you can buy a property
and then you can throw out there you
have title companies you don't have like
Land Registry you have title companies
and they hold the title to the property
and you just pay them a fee and it's
like buying a car they change your log
book that's all it is it's very very
simple it is so much simple in here Wow
that's whether you're gonna invest in
America then who knows you interested
who knows stop asking me questions I'm
not gonna tell you that I don't mean I'm
not shy about you personally lateral are
you interested in investing in America
yeah possibly importances sworn to
secrecy about challenges just secrecy
all I'll say you enjoying life oh who
knows although say is there's some
people out there making a lot of money
in property and property okay exciting I
was excited I'm really pressed
documentary don't forget to check it out
every Tuesday next next clip of Tuesday
I think yeah I think I come out on TV
Tuesday and the TV Tuesday good right
it's now time for this
[Music]
okay so this was recently on BBC News
interesting subject immediately we the
story first and well then we'll delve
into it so homely salt system needs
reform say MPs okay explain what this is
so the UK's leasehold system has left a
number of households in an unsellable
and on mortgageable homes and changes
are needed mps a often lease holders in
new build properties are treated as a
source of profit to help the the housing
communities local government says so it
says that the competition and marketing
authority should investigate mis-selling
claims the CMA should also make
suggestions regarding compensation they
say leasehold house owners are often
charged expensive ground rents as well
as fees if they want to make change to
their homes at least all the house can
also be difficult to sell developers say
that in all transactions builders aim to
provide prospective purchasers and their
solicitors and their mortgage lenders
with all the relevant information but
the h CL g committee said stories from
lease holders showed failings in the
process okay there's more but basically
I think I think I've talked to you about
this personally but it's like with
companies whether I build a big hat
they'll build a housing estate whatever
they'll do it as leasehold yeah the
ground rents low to begin with and
there's suddenly bang they up it to
something ridiculous yeah and they their
trap people in suddenly they can't sell
the property the ground the ground rent
is it's a typical ground rent and the
you I know it's the very everywhere but
in the UK typically what is it you know
roughly it's not generally a lot as a it
I mean when I said it's not a lot but
you're talking maybe a cup on the plane
a year in year what happen amidst is in
Birmingham in particular as higher it's
gone up a lot so what do you know if you
can add in a figure so yes you have
because I'm gonna tell you what the
figures are in America because it shock
does I'm just curious
average ground rents UK okay cuz mean
III know prop M probably czar like the
ground rents like 25 pound and 20 a
three-day to 400 per annum yeah
especially in London
an average new new leases range from 150
to 300 I think a year yeah I've got a
few they're not I can't remember the
exact figures they're not majorly high
um and you expect to pay something
because that they do do ya work so like
for instance in Liverpool it'd be
cheaper than it is in Birmingham so
we've just saw the property I hate your
more up in Liverpool and the ground rail
the ground rain was 28 pound a year 28
quid a year for the ground rent nothing
sir peanuts and for instance when we
were in the States on Simoes challenge
we looked at a couple of properties the
ground rate was 600 bucks a month a
month me red it's just crazy honestly
and when we ask the agents what do you
get for that well the more the lawn and
the they cover they cover up things like
the the the communal areas in the
building and things uh it's a lot it's
just crazy yeah well I think I I think
Taylor where I'm just checking it now
I think Taylor when people one of the
companies on and then if I'm wrong
demands who did that and they got caught
up in some yeah here we go
Taylor Wimpey most buyers in grammar and
scandal will be able to get new deals
there there was there was which is kind
of similar to this I mean Taylor Wimpey
are are phenomena like they're doing
massive developments everywhere aren't
they yeah so does that beg the question
are all the developments are doing
leasehold or are they doing any freehold
I think they're doing a lot of these
whole but should they be because if
they're building a newest a quite a
house isn't it because what will happen
is they do all these sort of schemes
don't they where you can like they'll
buy your part exchange your old home
they'll give you if you get to
valuations they'll give you the average
of that in the middle sense on
apartments because yeah you and me knows
in a communal building on a new estate
on a house because they have essentially
got you buy got you it's greedy
developers isn't it I think so yeah I
think it's greedy developers trusts
occasionally there must be there must be
some sort of control
put in the rain top without notice they
must have to give notice it's I think I
think it's in the contracts it's just
that people have missed it yeah this it
comes down to miss sailing because the
problem is you've got to imagine right
you are you're living in our to bed
house I don't know maybe you know maybe
a little bit of a pure area and then you
get the opportunity to move to a new
housing estate
we're Taylor Wimpey or another company
I'm going to buy your house off you for
a market value and then move in with
very little like sometimes they cover
your moving costs they cover all sorts
because they're more interested in
selling a new property then are an old
one yeah and they can afford to take a
little bit hit on the old one but my
point being is if you're you're there in
a vein you're a motivated buyer on hmm
you're in a position where you're an
people in an ocean with these houses but
I can treat they can't more exactly or
sell them you but you're fine they'll be
able to mortgage them to Taylor because
Taylor Wimpey I've got they can tour a
lot mortgages and stuff so there'll be
mortgaging them through the company but
then they can't remortgage them at a
later date yeah I think is good that the
MPS
know exactly what it they're the ins and
outs of it but yeah I think it's very
good yeah leasehold should not be around
on on houses now I apartments yeah but
not house it's yeah but if anyone's got
any any comments on that of anyone's in
a situation where they've bought a
leasehold house or they in trouble they
know a bit more about it be lovely to
hear your comments maybe we can address
on letters show but I think in
interesting news article very and be
aware of that if you're buying a house
be aware is it you know if it's
leasehold because it's an investment
property you probably screwed as well I
think I think just quickly it does come
down to just taking your emotions out of
things a little bit of your mind I know
it's an emotional purchase when you're
buying a home but sometimes take your
emotions out of it and read the
contracts properly yeah and read all the
stipulations and everything regarding
lease or payments I agree I agree great
awesome
right it's now time to answer your
questions
[Music]
so we got a question from Darren any
advice on the steps you take to find
your patch to invest in that's a really
good question it is actually thank you
down for that in fact you have actually
because we talked about this in detail
yet on the deal finding extravaganza I
moved so you wanna maybe just go through
one or two right okay so the patch your
gold main sort of area gold mine patch
waiver it needs to be somewhere where
you can buy a property relatively
affordable relatively cheap it's got the
potential to grow and value and it's got
high demand for tenants whether it be
single let's hit your malls or does
depend on what your strategy is so if
they should school with HMOs and because
it's nice and simple and so ideally it
once been a Turkish city a university
city ideally somewhere where there's
lots of jobs lots of the buzzing
nightlife lots of things going on and it
has to be where you can buy a property
affordably it's not ridiculously
expensive it's not you're not talking
hundreds of thousands of pounds you
maybe buy a 4-bedroom house for about
hundred thousand convert it do whatever
you've got to do it depends a little bit
on what your strategy is as well it
doesn't just said that if you were
listening
I wasn't ours also oh so you need to
have a grill good on some of the rules
and regulations in the area yeah so if
you're looking at HMOs and you're going
to look into compare it there's no point
going somewhere with us article four
because you have to then get planning
permission as well stuff so have a good
understanding of the rules have a good
understanding of the demand yeah and
have a good understanding of property
prices and what's gonna happen to the
property prices now we can't there's no
crystal ball here we're not gonna
predict we can't see in the future so
it's a it's a good estimation using due
diligence and research on property
prices in the US or like looking at
what's likely to happen in the area so
for example hs2 yeah crew for example
you guys okay it's probably gonna go up
because it's gonna be a lot easy to get
lunch yeah it's gonna make it more
valuable Birmingham the example is bring
up my Manchester we talked about a few
weeks ago
so we there's not crystal ball but yeah
but you can know another thing you can
look at his development in the area yeah
I was gonna say so for example Walsall
at the moment there's a hell of a lot of
development going into Warsaw so it's so
much smaller town yeah but they're
building a new hotels they're building
new restaurants that there were oh I
went in the city center of water for the
first time about three years the last
time I went there there were so many
shops that were empty yeah there are
still some but I was like wow there's a
lot a lot of new shopkins that names out
of coming it's looking a bit better than
it was yeah I think you just got
understand what's going on and if you
jump onto like the council pages and
things that aren't you can see what's
planned for the future so maybe three
four years away yeah
well perhaps it again there's bring a
lot more value at the moment so today
where they Blackpool and all people keep
criticizing them at Blackpool there's so
much to do so easy easy as much
criticises fun but there's a lot of
development planned in Blackpool there's
Lords and as they clap there's more
tales gonna I know a craphole I know
it's a [ __ ] all but um it is forget
forget that I can't forget it I've been
there yeah I know that and all that but
my point meanings you can buy houses
really really cheaper than minute I bet
you can um the problem is not problem
the good thing in ten years me I'm
telling you they're gonna be worth some
money because they're spending so much
money in Blackpool okay other places
such as Lancaster Lancaster's the same
the spending an awful lot of money the
University I think more money the UK in
generals be same thing
Lords and money being spent it would be
just a name puts me off yeah it's bit
grim but there's loads of money being
spent there and another thing is when
you're looking at your patch look and
see where like cost of coffees are open
in and premier inns things are up where
they're moving to the area because if
these are aliens going there another big
top you know my point being is they've
done the research for you hmm
why you've got a multinational chain
that you
chain of hotels I've done the research
on areas they know the footfall they
know the the likelihood of people going
to be there the event hotel was no
demand yeah so all interesting stuff and
get to know the area get to know the our
teams the arrow I saw stuff yeah awesome
great question Dara that's a really good
question down Thank You Darren right
next question this is off Ben Snooks
okay proud of me it's really in one go
one go bang when agreeing a rental
agreement is it best to go direct to
vendor or is it possible to go via the
letting agent as I understand they may
get confused path by your proposal if
you keep going rather letting agents to
keep them in the loop what advice you
okay awesome
great great question okay so let me tell
you the pros and cons of both south pros
director vendor is it's easier to get in
with them and to explain explain what it
is that you do it and it's easy for them
to understand it and to be good with it
so especially in the early days of doing
this you can go in places like wait
Gumtree and things like that you can
approach the vendors direct explain to
them what you're gonna do and that it's
I find it easier to get them than
letting agents that's the pro big pro of
a letting agent is once you get one on
board they get properties that keep
coming up coming up and if and if you
can convince them that what you're doing
is is good and that you'll be a good
tenant so to speak or someone will rent
the properties off them
it makes their life so easy because it
means that when they get a property come
up that they know you're fit the bill
they don't even got to put it on the
market they can just come straight at
you so that's a lot harder to get in
with the agent law yeah I would say to
get in with an agent it's gonna take
more than just a phone call yeah I mean
you're gonna have to come meet them you
have to go meet those builders build a
relationship with them if you've got one
that does both buying buying houses and
letting yeah and you can buy a few
houses off them and build a bit of a
relationship with them that what that
would obviously help so I know you're a
move because you deal source yeah it's
very easy for you to get him with a
buying stuff all the time
you're always connecting agents and
investors yeah and the I get so many
embed agents just call me yeah I think
got this don't wanna they've got this
I've got some before it yeah one of the
things we go through on the deal finding
extravaganza is a
I make live calls to these people
totally yeah I think I love that you
know it makes you really vulnerable
because you you know I've got a hundred
percent success right at the deer so far
happy really everyone's but I mean how
many times you've done it twice okay
that's good but still 100% success rate
yeah twice sealed a red turret deal over
the phone twice twice in a row
well from stage yeah I've always
listened to the calls and they are very
good like the the em I remember last
time that somebody hung up in you it
some point didn't he that was a that was
a DFA when he was in success rate what I
have had have had people answer yeah and
say things like oh it's not available
anymore I'm not counting that I'm
counting once I've actually got past
they've got it's available their habits
become and then I've pitched them on it
what we'll see laws you know do you know
him and in the in the states right the
property website he doesn't mention the
states today right okay so the property
websites like Zillow that's like where's
this sorry again and steve-o in the
state anyway New York was it that wasn't
that this is somewhere else but Zillow
is the equivalent to right move I
thought there was no cool until we found
it in the end
correct I have one criticize no we
didn't know they still oh and there I
would way did you oppose illa but before
we went to America know exactly it's a
wide know like we it was a random
country that we knew nothing about if we
knew about it then it wouldn't be no
come on get real guys anyway and so
Zillow the good thing about it and it
puts the property owners phone number on
there you have to be populist phone
number uzoma it's brilliant absolutely
brilliant how is that related to his
question because then you can go look on
Zillow if you're an America you can the
concealer and phone it own it or
indirect Wow to sell rate to vendor
leads us all so guys thanks ever so much
for tuning in this week do not forget to
hit the subscribe button you can also
listen to us if you're on the move on
Apple pod
just and spotify and all sorts places
like that you wanna just listen in and
we will see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]